sehr geehrte damen und herren wenn ihr
dieses video seht wenn sie dieses video
system geleitet entschuldigen sie bitte
diese unfähigkeit bin ich wahrscheinlich
gerade im sommerurlaub ist habe ich mir
gedacht habe in der vorproduktion machen
auch schön einfach und bestellen was
leckeres zum essen ich möchte nicht nur
etwas leckeres zu essen bestellen
sondern das leckerste zum essen
bestellen nämlich die empfehlung des
hauses ihr liegt sowieso diese das jetzt
mal die fälligkeiten seien ihr liegt
sowieso diese bestehe videos mehr als
aller videos ein wenig mitgefühl mühe
mache deshalb machen wir es heute auf
ganz entspannt wie gehabt haben wir hier
eine übersicht von restaurants aus dem
wir auswählen können bei denen wir
bestellt wir machen das so ich rufe
nicht sagt hey entscheiden was ist die
empfehlung des hauses was würden sie mir
empfehlen nicht ab weil die restaurant
gefallen wollte mir gerne was bestellen
was ist denn gut und genau das machen
wir mit drei restaurants wie immer und
legen direkt los indem wir uns das erste
raussuchen
[Musik]
alle midan al die maschen aromen aus dem
nahen osten
68 wertung vom 10 dann ist es heute
unsere aufgabe zu beweisen ist es nicht
ganz so schlecht ist hier ein bisschen
sorge weil 6,8 habe ich noch nie gesehen
in der damit eine chance geben ja ich
habe sorge weil ich habe echt hunger ich
hab kein bock dass das so schlecht ist
gleich bestellen die personen die dort
gestellt und bewertet haben ja einfach
nur das falsche deshalb lassen wir uns
mal die empfehlung des hauses geben und
bestellen die dann
ja nun hier magst kurze frage ich wollte
gerade was bei euch zu essen bestellen
ich wollte mal fragen was wäre so eine
empfehlung was was schmeckt jedem gut
[Applaus]
ben spies okay ich kann auf jeden fall
nur eine sache bestellen was ist was
würden sie mir empfehlen was mir
bestellen soll
[Musik]
ein panorama aber okay ja dann bestelle
ich mir im körper macht ihn lieben dank
ok danke schön
das drama ist ja eigentlich an und für
sich eine super leckere sachen bei rx
fuß ports als wir in bonn bahn habe ich
einen schabernack teller gegessen der
hat mir sehr sehr gut geschmeckt weshalb
muss ich sagen da habe ich jetzt hohe
erwartungen an diesen stellen gucken wir
mal ob es wirklich so man muss schon
fast sagen schlecht ist wie die
bewertung sagen weil man sieht wirklich
fast nie so eine bewertung wurde dadurch
nicht dass ein bisschen geschwätz wenn
wir haben gerade speedminton im büro
gespielt was man halt so macht hier ist
die bestellung von allen modernen
automaten 6,8 von 10 ja also nicht
verkehrt aus ist ein bisschen
durcheinander gekommen weil 6,8 das
stimmt bei der lieferung wissen
durcheinander gekommen aber bei 6,8
finde ich erwartet man ihr müsst bitte
verstehen dass stand zwar grad gut 6,8
aber ich hab echt noch nicht gesehen
also das ist so ziemlich die schlechte
bewertung überhaupt bei gold die mir
unter die augen gekommen ist neun euro
kostet das ganze und ich muss sagen du
kriegst wahrscheinlich nicht den umfang
von tellergerichte in einem laden
bekommt weil da sind ja so gesehen eine
handvoll pommes dabei einen gegner ich
probiere das wichtigste zuerst will ich
sein also gucken wir mal wie die pommes
überhaupt ankommen ich hatte nämlich die
sorge dass die wahrscheinlich total
lebendig ankommt ok komme es bestellen
ähnlich immer das sinnvollste und das
beste aber sie sind nicht so schlecht
dass das irgendwie sogar schlechte
bewertung rechtfertigen würde immer eine
knoblauchsoße hinter war das erste was
ich eigentlich auch relativ saftig aus
und eine schöne chance drin in die
knoten auch soße
also also ist es auf jeden fall nicht
verkehrt schmeckt eigentlich genau wie
bayerischer wald nur das arabische brot
ermessen wie viel besser es auf jeden
fall überhaupt nicht schlecht und man
könnte dadurch erwarten dass was
schlecht sagen können wenn man hier
finde ich auf diesen versteckten salat
schaut sieht so ein bisschen eingekauft
werden das finde ich auch nicht besser
sein so ist er ist ein koloss
sehr süß der ist es jetzt nicht
unbedingt was würde ich dem ganzen geben
und ich finde ich aber die sind super
lecker hat den typischen geschmack die
typischen gewürze aber ich finde dass
vor lecker also ich würde dem ganzen
glaubt 8,5 und zement city express rrx
spot mit zehn plus mit sternchen ist ab
geht die post wir gucken nach dem
zweiten restaurant bei dem wir bestellen
und ich bin gespannt wie da die
empfehlung lautet wird beziehungsweise
was ist an erster stelle überhaupt
erstmal ist vielleicht ist es bei den
angeschlossenen rechner aus beat
brothers 2.0 nicht schon ihren bereich
co2 und
fotos berger
ich hab's ausgewählt das ist es raus in
vietnam es krisen mit 9,2 das heißt den
bewertungen zufolge muss ich mir weniger
sorgen machen aber ich bin gespannt was
sie uns empfehlen werden
ja hallo hier max kurze frage ich wollte
gerade bei euch was zu essen bestellen
und wollte fragen ob ihr vielleicht eine
empfehlung habe weil ich nicht genau
weiß was sie auswählen soll
ich bin eigentlich ganz offen also
einfach so die empfehlung des hauses
ok super dann suche ich mal danach es
ist schon super vielen dank
herr mir empfohlen ente mit bandnudeln
das ist ente in den schein tamarinde so
wusste er nichts zurück blieben also
sehr sehr viele wäre zutaten preis
bandnudeln habe ich mir jetzt noch dazu
gemacht und ja ich glaube höhe stellen
15 99 beziehungsweise 13 99 weil ich
gesehen habe da waren schon beim buddeln
dabei stand zwar nicht aber es sieht
wenig aussagekräftig ausfindig der
geschmack muss überzeugen die optik ist
nicht verkehrt aber ist jetzt auch nicht
so dass man sagt dass das bestimmt das
beste was ich jemals gegessen habe aber
auch den lieferungen stunden nachdem die
forscher die kräuter und so die sind
wahrscheinlich alle im karton ein
bisschen eingegangen also knows so denkt
man so dass andere hat die bessere
bewertung und dass die schlechtere ja
das finde ich auch weiß der unterschied
wirklich dauert bewertung sehr deutlich
könnte man sogar ein
[Musik]
dass enten vielleicht durch superzahl so
crazy tamarine soße ist so schön süß
sauer
die nudeln haben genauso diesem bis dass
man die sich so rein schaufeln
ressourcen reis nudeln seien so sind die
auch bei partei sondern ein bisschen
süße dabei um diesen nudeln die so spaß
machen zu essen also schmeckt auf dem
fernseher lecker so sei das sehr
unscheinbar aus auch sowas niemals
bestellen genau dass das wollte ich auch
sagen es ist etwas was man wirklich
nicht bestellt hätte und man ist
trotzdem froh dass man es getan hat die
wies das gericht noch mal
kannst du so aussprechen sagt ruhig
talkshow gibt es auch - jetzt bewerten
müsste auf jeden fall wirklich besser
ist erst vor neun zweifeln sehr gelungen
ich bin froh dass ich das video gedreht
habe alleine weil ich dieses gericht
jetzt kenne ich werde auf jeden fall
noch mal bestellen fragt man nach der
empfehlung vielleicht werdet ihr positiv
überrascht auch zur nummer drei und wir
starten rein und machen uns auf die
suche kennt ihr spaß ich bin einfach ich
habe keine ahnung dass sie auswählen
werdet denn es ist die
hatten wir schon mal
für die jugend das heutzutage macht ist
hier in scrollen vision tippen
wie
release als terry dalls sehr gut von
denen gibt es nämlich sachen bei einem
online supermarkt bei dem anprall wurde
dass die sind sehr sehr lecker deshalb
denke ich dass die normalen speisen auch
köstlich sein werden und ich rufe da
einfach machen handynummern
heimat hier kurze frage ich wollte etwas
bestellen überrollt und ich dachte mir
weil ich voll uninspiriert bin ich frage
einfach mal was du empfehlen würdest
oder was ihr empfehlen wird
ist das alles ja
jack ist super die bestell ich danke
schön
klang sehr überzeugt von der ball
dementsprechend denke ich mir das sehr
gut sein wird wir bestellen und
probieren auch sie berichtet nummer drei
ein gericht was auf den ersten blick
etwas unscheinbar wirkt wir gucken mal
gemeinsam rein
halle wohl wirklich davon kann sich der
laden von theben scheibe abschneiden die
präsentation kann nämlich obwohl man das
ganze die fahrt bildhübsch sein und das
sieht man
ja ok bord sind immer gut ist was du
hast
[Musik]
so ein persönliches problem mit bols
aber wir gucken uns an diese lachs stück
hier sehen wirklich sehr sehr gut aus
wir haben auch trotz lieferungen noch
eine hörbare kruste einen schönen kraft
spinat drin auch der sekretär aus wie
vom feld
wenn man so ein dachs stückchen
sehr saftiger geschmack krank wäre zu
viel gesagt aber so wie es aussieht hat
das definitiv man probiere mal diesem
zitronen rice war ich glaube dass das
unüblich ist aber ich habe noch nie
zitronen reis gegessen wo er ist sehr
zitronig
[Musik]
er riecht erste chronik hat aber gar
keine zitronensäure thema den geschmack
von der zitronen zählt es gibt ja so
geschmack ohne teure säure hätte ich
auch ein bisschen komisch gefunden so
ist das überhaupt kein thema so viel
nicht richtig lecker ist es so fast ein
bisschen flora ein bisschen blumigen
geschmack geht sehr gut mit dem lachs
zusammen wir hier noch ein fehltritt von
mir geröstet und blumenkohl probieren
nur gerüchte um ein bisschen geschmack
bekommt probleme alles zusammen das
würde ich jetzt mal interessieren weil
das ist ja okay du kannst viele coole
sachen miteinander in einen hänger bowl
reinschmeißen aber ich finde sie haben
verstanden du hast bolt
haben geschrieben du musst statement
dazu
so sieht alles auf einem löffel aus und
wir werden den ultimativen test machen
macht alles auch gemeinsam sind oder an
eric seinen hass gegen wales
weiterführen
[Musik]
alles auf einmal ist auf jeden fall ein
bisschen überwältigend im geschmack
würde ich sagen weil so manche sachen
wie der sushi-bar und so ein bisschen
dominieren aber schmeckt auf keinen fall
schlecht also ich muss sagen von bot die
ich bisher gegessen hat ist das auf
jeden fall einer der geilsten weil die
macht ein bisschen was neu so dieser
zitronen reiste sonst hat man immer
diesen klebrigen reis oder man kann die
hälfte mit salat noch oder wieder noch
der reichste ist super galaxis super der
blumenkohl ist interessant zubereitet es
ist im boot spektrum und dem ich auch
nicht der allergrößte fan bin echt gut
welche note ich gerne mit der bewertung
8,8 wie so oft hat sich bewiesen
probiert was neues aus lohnt sich
vielleicht findet ihr wenn ihr mal so
nicht nur mit change macht wie ich heute
drei absolutes lieblingsgericht deshalb
immer schön ausprobieren immer ständig
videos schauen wir schon länger man ja
immer schön weiter machen leute danke
fürs zu sehen ist
[Musik]